cool hi everyone
um hi
um I'm Isabelle I'm a PhD student in the
NLP group uh it's uh about connecting
insights between NLP and Linguistics uh
yeah so hopefully we're going to learn
some some Linguistics and think about
some cool things about language uh some
Logistics uh we're in the project part
of the class which is cool uh we're so
excited to see everything you guys do uh
you should have a mentor greater
assigned
um uh through your project proposal uh
the person whoever graded your project
proposal uh you especially if you're in
a custom project you know we recommend
that you go to your graders office hours
it's uh they'll know the most and like
be most into your project uh and project
Milestones are due next Thursday so
that's in one week from now so hopefully
you guys are all getting uh
warm warmed up doing some some things
for the project and we'd love to hear
where you are next week
cool
so
um the main thing that I'm going to talk
about today is is that there there's
been kind of a paradigm shift uh for the
role of linguistics uh in NLP do due to
large language models right so it used
to be that uh you know there was just
human language we created all the time
we're literally constantly creating it
and then we would like analyze it in all
these ways you know maybe we want to
make trees out of it maybe want to make
different types of trees out of it uh
and and then with all that would would
kind of go into making some kind of
computer system that can use language
right and and now we've we kind of we've
cut out this middle part right so so we
have human language and we can just like
immediately train uh um uh a system
that's like very competent in human
language and so now we have all this
like analysis stuff from before uh and
and from and and and we're still
producing more and more of it right
there's still all the structure all this
knowledge that we know about language
and the question is you know is this
relevant at all to and healthy and today
I'm gonna show how like it's useful for
looking at these models understanding
the these models understanding how how
things work what we can expect what we
can't expect uh from from uh large large
language models so in this lecture we'll
you know learn learn some some
Linguistics hopefully language is you
know an amazing thing it's like so fun
to think about language and hopefully we
can instill some of that in you maybe
you'll go take like link one or
something after this
um and and we'll discuss some some
questions about NLP and Linguistics
right where does Linguistics fit in for
today's NLP and what and what does NLP
have to gain from knowing and analyzing
human language you know what is like a
224n student have have to gain from from
knowing all this stuff about human
language
so so the for the lecture today we're
going to start off
um
uh talking about structure in human
language doing thing thinking about like
the Linguistics of syntax and how
structure works in language we're gonna
um then move on to like a linguistic
structure in NLP in language models the
kind of analysis that people have done
uh for for for understanding structure
in NLP and then we're going to think of
going Beyond pure structure so so beyond
thinking about syntax thinking about how
like meaning and um yeah how like
meaning and discourse and all of that
play into making language and how you
know and how we can think of this both
from a linguistic side and from a deep
learning side uh and then lastly we're
going to look at multilinguality and
language diversity in in NLP
cool
so Stars starting off a structure in
human language
um you know just just like a small
primer in language in general right uh
it's it's a kind of if you've taken any
Android Linguistics class you only know
all of this but you know I think it's
fun to get kind of situated in the
amazingness of this stuff right so like
all all humans have language and no
other animal communication is similar
it's this thing which is like incredibly
just like
um easy for any baby to pick up in any
situation and um and it's just this like
remarkably calm complex system very
famously you know linguist uh like to to
talk about the case of Nicaragua and
sign language because it um it uh
uh it kind of emerged like while people
were watching in a great way right so
like after the sentiment used to
Revolution
um you know they they started uh there's
there's like kind of large public
education in Nicaragua and they made a
school for for uh for Deaf children and
and there was no Central Nicaraguan sign
language people had like isolated
language and then you see this like full
language emerge in this school very very
autonomous autonomously very naturally I
hope this is this is common knowledge
maybe it's not you know signed languages
are like full languages with like more
morphology and and like things like
pronouns and tenses and like all the
things it's not like how I would talk to
you across the room uh yeah and so and
what's cool about language is that it
can be manipulated to say infinite
things right and and the brain is finite
so it's either we have some kind of set
of rules that were like
that we like tend to be able to pick up
from from from hearing them as a baby
and then be able to say infinite things
and we can manipulate these rules to
really say anything right we can talk
about things that don't exist things
that can't exist this is very different
from like the kind of animal
communication we see like a squirrel
like alarm call or something you know
it's like watch out there's the cat
um
uh things are like totally abstract you
know that have like no no grounding in
anything we can express like some subtle
differences between similar things I
always when I'm thinking about like the
this point in like um things called yeah
like this featured languages think of
like the stack exchange World building
uh thing I don't know if you ever looked
at the sidebar where there's then
there's like thing where like science
fiction authors kind of pitch uh like
their ideas for like their science
fiction world and it's like the wackiest
like and you can really create any world
with like with within English with a
language that that we're given it's it's
like amazing and so there's structure
underlying language right this is I said
recap here because we've done like the
dependency parsing lectures we thought
about this right but you know if if we
have some some sentence like you know
Isabel broke the window the window was
broken by Isabel right we have these two
sentences or some kind of relation
between them and then and then we have
another two sentences they have like the
similar relation between them right this
kind of passive alternation it's kind of
something which exists for both of these
sentences you know and then we can even
use like made up words and uh it's still
you can still see that it's a passive
alternation right and so it seems like
we have some knowledge of structure
that's separate from from the words we
use and the things we say that's kind of
above it
and then what's interesting about
structure is that it dictates how we can
use language right so you know if if I
have a sentence like the cat sat on the
mat and it's and it looks uh
uh you know and and then someone tells
you like well this is you know if you
make a tree if it's going to look like
this according to my type of tree Theory
um you would say well why should I care
about that and the reason that this
stuff is relevant is because
um it kind of influences what you could
do right so like any subtree or like you
know in this specific case any subtree
in other cases like many sub trees it
can kind of be real real replaced with
like one item right because like he sat
on the mat or he sat on it or he sat
there right or he did so
it's those two words but you know
there's a lot of ink spilled overdue in
English especially in like early
Linguistics teaching so we're not going
to spill anything it's kind of like one
word um but then when something is not a
sub tree you like can't really replace
it with one thing right so you so you
can't express like the cat's sat and
they kind of like have the mat as a
different thing right and one you could
feel like he did so on the mat right
you'd have to kind of do to do things
and like and and one way you could think
about this is that well it's not a sub
tree right it's kind of like you kind of
have have to go up a level uh to to to
do this and so you can't really separate
the cat from on the mat in this way
and so and we implicitly know like so
many complex rules about structure right
we're like processing the these like
streams of sound or like streams of
letters all the time and yet we like
have these like the ways that we use
them show that we have all these like
complex ideas like the tree I just
showed or like for for example these are
like I'm just gonna give some examples
for like a a taste of like the kinds of
things people are thinking about now but
there's like so many right so like what
can we pull out to make a question right
so like if we form a former question we
we form it by like we we're kind of
referring to some part of like you know
there might be another sentence which
like is the statement version right and
we've kind of pulled pulled pulled out
some some part to make the question
they're not necessarily like fully
related but you know so it's like Leon
is a doctor we can kind of pull pull
that out to make a question right like
what is Leon and if we have like my cat
likes tuna we could pull that out what
does my cat like again do ignore the do
um if we have something like Leon is a
doctor and an activist we actually we
can't pull out this the this last thing
right so if something's like in this if
something's like conjoined with an and
we it can't like be be taken out of that
and right so you you could only say what
is Leon think he's like oh a doctor and
an activist but you can't really say
what is the on a doctor and this is like
not how question formation works and you
know this is like some something that we
all know it's I think something any of
us have been taught right even people
who've been taught English as a second
language I don't think this is something
which you're ever
um which whichever really taught
explicitly right but but but most of us
probably know this very well
um
uh another such rule right is like when
is like this is like when can we kind of
shovel things around right so if we have
something like I dictated the letter to
my secretary right uh we can make like a
longer version of that right I dictated
the letter that I had been
procrastinating writing for weeks and
weeks to my secretary
um this character is like both a grad
student and like a high ranking
executive
um and and then we can we can move the
uh we we can move that that long thing
to the end right it's like I dictated it
to my secretary of the letter that I've
been procrastinating writing for weeks
and weeks and that's like fine you know
maybe it's like slightly awkwardly
phrased but it's not like I think like
this firm for me at least everyone
varies right could could appear in like
natural productive speech but then
something like this is like much worse
right so somehow the fact that it
becomes weighty is good and you we can
move it to the end but when it doesn't
become weighty we can't right and we
like this sounds kind of more like Yoda
e than like real language and so and so
like and we have this rule like this
one's not that easy to explain actually
like people have tried many ways like to
like make sense of this in linguistics
and it's just like but it's a thing we
all know right and and so when I say
rules of grammar these are not the kind
of rules that we're usually taught as
rules of grammar right so a a community
of speakers you know for example like
standard American English speakers they
share this rough consensus of like the
implicit rules they all have these are
not the same you know like people have
like gradations and disagree on things
but you know and then kind of like a
grammar is an attempt to describe all
all these rules right and you can like
kind of linguist might write out like a
big thing called like you know the like
grammar of the English language where
they're trying to just describe all of
them it's like really not going to be
um large enough ever like this is a
really Hefty book and it's like not
still not describing all of them right
like language is so complex but so what
so what we are told is rules of grammar
you know these kind of like prescriptive
rules where they tell us what what we
can and can't do you know they often
have other purposes in describing the
English language right so for example
when they've told us things like oh you
should never start a sentence with and
you know that's like not true you know
we start tennis we land all the time in
English and it's fine uh uh you know
what they probably mean you know there's
some probably like
reason that they're saying this right
like especially if you're like trying to
teach a high schooler to like write you
know you're probably when you want them
to focus their thoughts you probably
don't want them to be like oh and this
oh and this again you know like you want
them to like and so you tell them like
oh a rule of writing you know is like
it's like you can never start sentence
with and right and when they say
something like oh it's incorrect to say
I don't want nothing this is like bad
grammar you know well this is you know
in in standard American English you
probably wouldn't have nothing there
right because uh you you would have
anything right but but in many dialects
of English you know any many languages
across the world when you have a
negation right like the not and don't
then like everything it kind of Scopes
over also has to be negative has to
agree and many dialects of English are
like this and so what they're really
telling you is you know the dialect with
the most power in the United States
doesn't do negation this way and so you
should neither in school right and
and and so you know and so the way that
we can maybe Define grammaticality right
rather than like what they tell us is
wrong or right is that you know if we
choose a community of speakers to look
into they share this rough consensus of
their implicit rules and so like the
utterances that we can generate from
these rules you know are grammatical uh
roughly you know everyone has these like
gradations of what they can accept and
if we can't produce an utterance using
these rules you know it's ungrammatical
and that's where like this is like the
descriptive way of thinking about
grammar where we're where we're thinking
about uh what people actually saying
what people actually like and don't like
and so for an example you know in in
English largely we have a pretty strict
rule that like the subject the verb and
the object appear in this like SVO order
there's exceptions to this like there's
acceptance everything right expression
things like says I and some dialects but
you know it is like largely if something
is before the verb it's a subject
something is after the verb it's an
object and you can't move that around
too much and uh you know we also have
these subject pronouns you know like I I
shahide that have to be the subject and
these object pronouns you know me me her
him them that have to be the object and
uh
and you know and so if we follow the
these rules we get a sense that we think
is is good right like I love her and if
we don't then we get a sentence that we
think is is ungrammatical right
something like me love she it's like we
don't know who is who
um you know who's doing the loving and
and who is being loved in in this one
right and it's
doesn't exactly parse and this is like
also true you know like even when
there's ambiguity this continues to be
true right so for a sentence like me a
cupcake eight which is like the meaning
is perfectly clear uh our rules of
grammaticality don't seem to cut to cut
as much slack right we're like oh this
is wrong I understand what you mean but
in my head I I know it's like not you
know correct even not not by the like
prescriptive notion of what I think is
correct you know by the descriptive
notion like my I just don't don't like
it right
and uh you can also you know sentences
can be grammatical without any meaning
so you can have meaning with that
grammaticality right like me a cupcake
eight and you could also have it's like
classic uh
uh example from from Chomsky in 1957
um I introduced it earlier uh but yeah
classically from 1957 uh you know
colorless green ideas sleep sleep
furiously right which like this has no
meaning because you can't really make
any sense out of this sentence as a
whole but you know you know it's
grammatical and you know it's
grammatical right because you can make
an ungrammatical version of it right
like color screen ideas sleeps Furious
right which does make sense because
there's no agreement even though you
don't have any meaning for any of this
and then lastly
um you know people don't fully agree you
know everyone has their own idiotic
right people like usually speak like
more than one dialect and they kind of
move between them and they have a
mixture and those have like their own
way of thinking of things they also have
these like those have different opinions
at the margins people like like some
things more uh others don't right so an
example of this is like not everyone is
as strict for some wh constraints right
so if you're trying to pull out
something like I saw who Emma doubted
report that would capture in the
Nationwide FBI Manhunt was from a paper
by uh Hofmeister knives and sag from
Stanford uh this is like some people
like it some people don't you know it's
kind of some people can like clearly see
it's like oh it's the who that we had
captured and Emma doubted the reports
that we had captured them you know and
some people are like this is as bad as
like
uh what is the other doctor and I don't
like it right
so yeah
so that's grammaticality and the
question is like why do we even need
this right it's like we we like we like
accept these useless utterances and we
block out these perfectly communicative
utterances right and and this is like I
started off saying that this is like a
fundamental facet of human intelligence
like it seems kind of you know a strange
thing to have
and so I think one thing I keep
returning on when I think about
Linguistics is that a basic fact about
language is that is that we can say
anything right there's like really
every language you know can express
anything you know and it's like there's
no word for something people will
develop it if they want to talk about it
right and so if we ignore the rules
because we know what it's probably
intended right uh you know and then
we'll be limiting possibilities right so
in my kitchen horror novel where the
ingredients become sentient I want to
say the onion chop the chef and if
people if if people just assumed I meant
the chef chopped the onion because like
SVO order doesn't really matter then uh
I can't I can't say that
so then yeah to
to like to
conclude you know a fact about language
that that's like
very cool is that it's compositional
right we have the set of rules that
defines grammaticality and then this
like
um and then this lexicon right this like
dictionary of words that that relate the
world want to talk to them and kind of
combine them in these Limitless ways to
say anything we want to say
cool any questions about all this I've
like tried to bring a lot of like
linguistic fun facts like top of mind
for this lecture so I'll hopefully
hopefully have answers for things you
want to ask
cool
cool yeah
um
cool so so now you know that was a nice
foray into like a lot of like 60s
Linguistics
um you know how how does that relate to
us like today
right in NLP and
um so we said that in humans you know
like we can think about languages it's
like there's a system for producing
language you know that can be described
by these discrete rules you know so it's
not like it's smaller than all the
things that we can say they're just kind
of like rules that we can kind of put
together to say things
and so do NLP systems work work like
that and one answer is like well they
definitely used to right because as you
said in the beginning before self
supervised learning uh the way to
approach doing NLP was through
um
understanding the human language system
right and then trying to imitate it
trying to see if you think really really
hard about how humans do something then
you kind of like code up a computer to
to do it right and so for for one
example is like you know parsing used to
be like super important in in in in NLP
right so and this is because you know as
an example if I want my sentiment
analysis system to classify a movie
review correctly right something like my
uncultured roommate hated this movie but
I absolutely loved it right How would
how would we do this before we had like
cha gbt
um we we we we you know we might have
some semantic representation of words
like hate and uncultured you know it's
not looking good for the movies but you
know how how does everything relate well
you know we we might ask how would human
structure this word you know so many
linguists you know there's many theories
of how to make you know of how syntax
might work but they would tell you some
some something like this so it's like
okay I know I'm interested in the eye
right because that's like probably what
what the review relates to they're just
worrying stuff about uncultured and
hated but it seems like those are
related like syntactically together
right it's like the roommate hated and
that can't really connect to the eye
right so the eye can can't really
um be related to the hated right because
there's kind of separated they're like
separate Sub sub trees separated by this
like conjunction by this but relation
um and and so and so it seems that I
goes with love which is looking good for
the movie let me know we have loved it
and so then we have to move beyond the
rules of of syntax right the rules of
like discourse how how would this kind
of you know like what could it mean you
know there's like a bunch of rules of
discourse and if you say it you're
probably referring to like the latest
kind of salient thing that's you know
matches and like you know it is probably
non-sentient right and so you know in
this case it would be movie right
so so so then you know like
linguistic Theory you know they helped
NLP uh it helped NLP reverse engineer
language so you had something like input
you know get like syntax from it you get
semantics from from the syntax right so
you would take the tree and then from
the tree kind of build up all these like
little you know like you you you you can
build up these little functions of like
how how how things how things like
relate to each other then and then you
you could go to discourse right so so so
so what refers to what what what nouns
are being talked about what things are
being talked about and you know and and
then whatever else was interesting for
your specific uh
uh uh uh use case
now we don't need all that right
language models just seem to catch on to
a lot of these things right so so this
whole thing that I did with the tree is
like Chachi bitty know this I know it's
much harder things than this right this
was like this isn't even like slightly
prompt engineer that just like woke up
one morning was like gotta do the rest
of the lecture gonna put that into chat
GPT and this exactly you know I didn't
even get some like yeah stop well I
guess I got a bit of moralizing but I
just like immediately uh immediately
just told told me you know who likes it
who doesn't like it and why I'm doing
something like slightly uh wrong uh
which is How It Ends everything right
um
and so and so you know NLP systems
definitely used to uh this is where we
were you uh work in this kind of
structured discrete way but now NLP
works better than it ever has before and
we're not constraining our systems to
know any sense syntax right so what what
about structure in modern language
models uh and so
um this question is like do the
questions like a lot of analysis work
has has has been focused on you know I
think we'll have more analysis lectures
later also so this is going to be you
know looked in more detail right is how
could you get from training data you
know which is just kind of like a loose
set of just things that have appeared on
the Internet or sometimes not on the
internet rarely right to rules about
language right to to to to the idea that
there's this like structure underlying
language that we all seem to know even
though we do just talk in streams of
things
and sometimes up here on the internet
and one way to think about this is like
testing
um you know is testing how novel words
and old structures work right so humans
can easily integrate new words into our
old sense and tactic structures I
remember like
I had lived in Greece for a few years
for Middle School just speak not
speaking English too much and I came
back for high school and uh
and um
yeah and and this is like in in Berkeley
in this way and there was like there was
literally like 10 new vocabulary words
I'd like never heard of before and they
all had like a very similar role to like
dank or like sick you know but they were
like the ones that were being tested out
and did not pass and within like one you
know one day I immediately knew how to
use all of them right it was not it was
not like a hard thing for me I didn't
have to like get a bunch of training
data uh about how how to use you know
all these words right and so this kind
of like is is one way of arguing that
you know the thing I was arguing for the
whole first part of the lecture that
syntactic structures they exist
independently of the words that they
have appeared with right uh a famous
example of this is um is Lewis Lewis
Carroll's poem Jabra walking right I was
going to quote from it but I can't
actually see it there right where they
uh where they uh you know where he just
like made up a bunch of new words and he
just made this poem which is all new
open class words open class words what
we call you know kind of like nouns
verbs adjectives adverbs classes of
words that like we add new things to all
the time while while things like
conjunctions you know like and or but
are closed class of there's been a new
conjunction added late added recently I
just remembered after I said that who
does anyone know like of a contraction
that's in the past like 30 years or
something maybe 40. all right spoken
slash like now we say slash and it kind
of has a meaning that's like not and or
but or or or or but it's a new one but
it's closed Clash generally this happens
rarely
anyway and and so you know you you you
you have like twist brilliant and the
slightly toes did guyron Gimbal and the
wave right toves is a noun we all know
that we've never heard it before and in
fact you know one word for from from
Jabberwocky Turtle actually entered the
English vocabulary right it kind of
means like a like a little chuckle
that's maybe slightly suppressed or
something right so so so it shows like
you know there was one literally like
one example of this word and then people
picked it up and started using it as if
it was a real word right so and so one
one way of asking um a do language
models have structures like do they have
this ability
and you know and I always think it would
be cool to go over like a benchmark
about this right so like the kind of
things so people like make things where
you could test your language models to
to see if it does this
um yeah are there any questions until
now if I go into just like this new
benchmark
cool so yeah the cogs Benchmark is a
compositional generalization from
semantics uh Benchmark or something
right it kind of checks if if language
models can uh can can do new words
structure combinations right so so the
the task at hand is semantic
interpretation this is I kind of glossed
over it before but it's like if you have
if you have a sentence right like the
girls saw the Hedgehog you have this
idea that like and you've seen what like
saw is a function that takes in two
arguments and it outputs that the first
one saw the second one you know this is
like a bit of like you know
um this is like one way of thinking
about semantics there's many more as
we'll see but you know this is one and
so like and so and so you can make a
little like kind of Lambda expression
about uh you know about uh how how
how you know what the sentence means and
to get that you kind of have to use the
the the tree to get it correct but
um anyway the the specific mechanism is
not very important but it's like the
semantic interpretation where you take
the girl saw the Hedgehog and you and
you add put this like function of like
you know C takes two two arguments you
know first is a girl second is the head
job and then and then the training of
the test set they have distinct words
and structures in in different roles
right so so so for example you know you
you have things like Paula right or the
Hedgehog is like always an object in the
in the training data so when you're
fine-tuning to do this task but then in
the test data it's a subject right so
it's like can can can you like can you
can you use this uh word that you've
seen you know in in a new kind in in a
new place because in English anything
that that that that's an object can be a
subject you know with like some there's
some subtlety around like some things
are more likely to be subjects but yeah
and then similarly you know if if you
have something like the cat on the mat
you know and it always appears so so
this idea that that like a noun can go
with like a prepositional phrase right
but that's always always in the subject
whether Emma saw the cat in the mat and
then like can can you do something like
you know the cat on the mat saw Mary
right so it's like move that kind of
structure to subject position which
something that in English we can do
right like any type of noun phrase that
can be in an object position can be in
subject position and so that and so
that's the the cogs Benchmark you know
large language models have an Asus yet I
wrote This and like I was looking over
the slide and I was like well we haven't
checked the largest ones you know they
never do check the largest ones for
because it's really hard to like do this
kind of more more like analysis work you
know and things move so far it has like
the really large one let's go T5 3
billion you know three billions like a
large number it's maybe not a large
language model anymore but um you know
they don't Ace this right they're
they're getting like 80 well like when
they don't have to do the structural
generalization when they can just like
do like a test set which which like
things appear in the same role as they
did in training set they get like 100
easy it's not a very hard task and so
you know this is like
but still still pretty good you know and
it's probably like
if a human had never ever seen something
in subject position I'm not sure that it
would be like 100 as easy as if they had
you know like I think that you know we
don't want to fully idealize how how
things were were working humans right
similarly you can take literal
Jabberwocky sentences right so uh so so
build building on some some work that
John did then I'm just gonna talk about
later so I'm not going to go in but
maybe I'm wrong on that assumption right
we can like kind of test the models like
embedding space right so if we go high
up in the layers and test the embedding
space we can test it to see if it
encodes structural information right and
and so we can test you like okay is
there like a a rough representation of
like
syntactic tree relations in this uh
latent space and uh and and then these
um yeah and then a recent paper asked
does this work when we introduce new
words right so if we so if we take uh
you know if we take like Jabberwocky
style sentences and then ask can the
model find out these the the trees and
these in its latent space does it like
uh
uh encode them and and and and the
answer is you know like it's kind of
worse you know in in this graph the uh
the hatched bars or the ones on the
right are the Jabberwocky sentences and
the um and the and the clear ones or the
not hatch ones I guess are are the ones
are are the normal sentences in which
you know performance is worse you know
so this is like unlabeled attachment
score on the y-axis it is like you know
first probably worse in humans right
it's easier to read a normal poem than
to read Jabberwocky so you know the
extent to which this is like damning or
something you know is that I think very
very small I think the paper is I have
linked it there but you know I think the
paper is maybe a bit more um
um
uh sure about this being a big deal
maybe then it is but yeah you know it it
does show that that this kind of process
isn't um trivial yeah
it's like applies for walking
substitutions oh so this is um this is
uh something called like phono tactics
right so so in uh I think like this is
probably around kind of what you're
asking is that it's like you want a word
which sounds like it could be in English
right like Pro like provocated right
it's not that can't be in English you
know classical example you're like Blick
it could be an English word you know
Nick can't right we can't start sentence
with bien and that's not like an
impossibility of like the mouth right
it's like you know uh similar things
like you know pterodactyl pneumonia you
know like these come from like Greek
Greek words like
I can say them I'm a Greek native
speaker like PN and PT I can put them at
the beginning of a syllable you know but
like in English they they they don't go
and so like if you kind of follow these
rules you know and like kind of also add
like the correct like suffixes and stuff
right so like proud Paul vacated we know
is like past tense and stuff then
then yeah then you can make kind of
words that that don't
um exist but could exist and so they
don't like throw people off this is
important for the tokenizers right you
don't want to do something like totally
wacky to to to to to test the models but
um yeah
so when you generate
um like this test set like with these
Java Rock substitutions are these words
generated by like a computer or like is
there a human like coming up with words
that sound like English but all the time
there's some like uh there's some like
databases that you know people have like
thought of these and like the I think
they get theirs from some like there's
some list of them you know because if
you have like 200 that's like enough to
run this test because it's like a test
but uh but
um
yeah I mean I think that you know the
phonotactic rules of English can be
actually laid out kind of Simply you
know it's like you you know like PTU
like can't really have like two stops to
get you know it's like they're both like
the same you can't really put them
together you know it's like you you can
probably make like a short program or
like a long-ish program but not like a
very super complex one to like make good
Jabberwocky words in English yeah
yeah wondering how the model would
tokenize these Java Rocky sentences like
would it not just Mount all these words
like publicated just like the unknown
difference so um
um so so these are largely models that
have like uh word wordpiece tokenizers
right so they like kind of so if they
don't know where they're like okay
what's like the largest bit of it that I
know and then like that's like a sub
token right and this is how like most
models work now it's like back in the
day and this is like back in the day
meeting like until like maybe like six
or seven years ago it was like very
normal to have tokens like unknown
tokens but now generally there is no
such thing as an unknown right you put
like kind of at a bare minimum you have
like the alphabet in your vocabulary so
I got a bare minimum you're splitting
everything up into like you know like
letter by letter tokens character by
character tokens but um if you're not
then um yeah it's
it should
um yeah it should find kind of like and
this is why like the phonotactic stuff
is is kind of is kind of important for
this right that it's it tokenizes like
hopefully in like slight slightly bigger
chunks that have some meaning and like
because of how attention works and how
contextualization works you can like
even if you have like a little bit of a
word you can like give you know uh the
the correct kind of attention to it once
it figures out what's going on a few
layers in you know for like a real
unknown word for like a fake unknown
word then you know
cool
I went back but I want to go forward
cool any more questions about anything
yeah
it was uh like 80 20 scores that you
were saying these are not
um like this isn't myself probably yet
I'm just trying to get a sense of what
80 means that context is like 80 of
exact
ly yeah it was it was exact I think like
the relevant comparison is that what you
didn't have this kind of structural
difference you know where where like
something that was sometimes a subject
was like then like was like something
which was like never an object was that
an object you know the the like the the
the the the accuracy on the on that test
set is like 100 like easy and so and so
and so it kind of there was no good
graph which showed these next to each
other they kind of mentioned it but uh
yeah and so I think like that's like the
relevant
um piece of information that like
somehow this like SWA swapping around of
roles like kind of slightly trips it up
that being said you're right like exact
match of semantic Parts is kind of a
hard metric you know and so and so it's
not this is yeah none of this stuff and
I think this is important none of this
stuff is damning none of this stuff is
like they do not have the kind of rules
human have this is also I was like well
there's a bit of confusion there's a bit
of fusion in humans it actually gets
quite a bit it gets quite subtle with
humans and I'm gonna go into that in the
next section too
yeah overall
uh sorry what is it yeah overall like I
think the results are like surprisingly
not damning I would say yeah this is the
there's like clear clearly like you know
maybe not the fully like programmed
discrete kind of rules but yeah
I would say cool uh another thing we
could do uh yeah test how syntactic
structure kind of maps onto like meaning
and role right and so like uh as we said
before right like in English a syntax of
word order it gives us the who did what
to whom meaning and so you know if we
have if we have like you know for for
any combinations like a verb and B if
has something like a verb B we know like
a is a do or B is the patient
and so he has like is this kind of uh
relationship you know um strictly
represented in English language models
as it is like in the English language
and and so and so what we could do is
that we could take a bunch of things
which like you know appear in subject
position a person would appearance
object position and uh um and and put in
and take their late late in space
representation and uh and kind of learn
learn you know learn learn like a little
classifier you know this should be like
a pretty clear distinction in latency in
any like good model right like which
like these models are good this should
be a pretty clear distinction because
it's like a linear classifier to kind of
separate them right and the more on the
one side you are you're more subject the
more the other side you're you're more
object
right and and so then we we we can test
you know does the model know
um the difference you know be between
when something is a subject and when
some something is an object you know
doesn't know that like you're going to
go on opposite sides of of this um of
this uh
uh dividing line you know even if like
everything else stays stay stay the same
and all the clues point to just to
something else right so it's like this
index map on to roll in this way you
might think like well I could just check
if it's like second or like fifth right
but you know we've actually we we yeah
this is a period that I wrote you know
we did like compare you know we like try
to control for like
position stuff in in various ways and
these are like yeah and and so it's
hopefully we claim we're kind of showing
like the like syntax to roll mapping
and what we see is that it does right so
so so if we kind of graph the uh the the
the
distance from that dividing line you
know on the y-axis which is like the the
like the original subjects when we swap
them and
put them in object position they do like
diverge as we go up layers in that um in
that Dimension and we tried this again
you know all this analysis experience
isn't kind of small models with some
bird would so gpt2 you know it's like a
bigger version of gpt2 and it worked out
but but it's like you know none of this
is like you know
um none of this is like the big big
stuff I think now we're starting to see
more analysis on the big big stuff I
think it's really cool
yeah uh so then where are we with like
structure and language models right we
know that uh we know that language
models are not aren't they're not
engineered around discrete linguistic
rules but the pre-training process you
know it isn't just a bunch of surface
level memorization right we have seen
this there is some kind of like the uh
discrete
rule-based system kind of coming out of
this you know maybe it's not the perfect
kind of thing you would like write down
in a syntax class but you know there is
some syntactic knowledge you know and
it's complicated in various ways and
humans are also complicated and that's
what we're going to get to next right
there's no ground Truth for how language
Works yet right like if we knew how to
fully describe English right with a
bunch of good discrete rules we would
just like make an old pipe Pi pipeline
system and it would be amazing right if
we could like take the Cambridge grammar
of English but like it was truly truly
complete if we just knew who knew how
English worked we would do that and so
we're working in this case where there's
no really no ground truth cool any
questions about this probably move
Beyond syntactic structure
cool
so uh moving beyond this kind of like
very structure-based uh idea of language
and I think it's very cool to learn
about structure in this way and like at
least how I was taught Linguistics it
was like a lot of it the first like many
semesters uh
uh was like this kind of stuff
um but then but but I think there's like
so much more and and and like very
important I think that meaning plays a
role in in linguistics
structure right like there's a lot of
Rich information in words that that
affects like the final way that like the
the syntax works and of course what like
end up meaning and like what like the
words influence each other to mean right
and so like the the semantics of words
right the meaning it's like always
playing a role in forming and applying
the the rules of language right and so
you know for example like a classic
example is like you know verbs they like
have kind of like selectional
restrictions like eight can like take
kind of any food and it can also take
nothing I was like I ate it means that
I've just like I've eaten right devoured
right the word devoured actually can't
can't be used in transitively right it
sounds weird you you need to to devour
something right there's verbs like
elapsed that only take like you know a
very certain type of noun right like
elapsed only takes Downs that that uh
that uh for the time you know so maybe
like Harvest can refer to time Moon can
refer to time some somewhere you know
it's trees it cannot take over like
trees right there's even verbs that only
ever take one specific noun as their
argument right it's like classic example
um I think yeah my advisor Dan dendroski
told me this one to put it in
um and and what's cool is that like that
that's how we train models these days if
you see this uh this um diagram I
screenshotted from John's Transformers
lecture right we start with a rich
semantic input right we start with these
like a thousand on the order of like a
thousand you know depending on the model
size embeddings right which it's like
think of how much information you can
express like on a plane right on two
Dimensions it's like the kind of
richness that you can fit into a
thousand Dimensions you know it's huge
and we start with these word word
embeddings and then move on right it's
like the attention block and and
everything
and so yeah I'm just going to go through
some examples of the ways that that
languages you know the ways that like
meaning kind of plays a role in forming
syntax hopefully it's like fun a tour
through like the cool things that happen
in language
right so as we said you know anything
can be an object anything can be a
subject we want to be able to say
anything language can like Express
anything this is like kind of a basic
part of language but you know many
languages they have a special syntactic
way of dealing with this right so they
want to tell you like if there's an
object that you wouldn't expect right
like in this case someone tell you hey
watch out you know the be careful we're
dealing with with a weird object here
right so this is like kind of in the
syntax of languages mode you know if
you're if you're if you're a native
speaker or or you've learned Spanish
right you know this like ah constraint
right so if you say like you know so if
something is a um is an object but it's
inanimate you don't need the ah because
you're like yeah I found a problem but
then if you're putting something adamant
in the object position you need to kind
of Mark it you need like hey watch out
you know there's an object here and it's
like a rule of the grammar right like if
you don't do this it's wrong and they
tell you this in Spanish class
um
similarly like Hindi has a kind of a
more subtle one but I think it's cool
right so you uh
um to if if you put an object that is
definite you have to mark it with a
little like this is an object marker
right like a little accusative marker
right and like you might ask okay I
understand why like animacy is uh is uh
is is
um is a big deal right like you know
maybe animate things more often do
things than have things done to them but
like why why why definiteness right like
why why would you need this little like
call Marker just like the goat versus a
goat and it's like well if something is
definite it means that it's like it
means that that it's like in the kind of
in we've like kind of probably been
talking about it or we're all thinking
about it you know for example like oh I
ate the apple right this means that
either like we had one apple left and I
ate it or like it was like really rotten
or something you can't believe I ate it
right or something like that and so like
then things that we're already talking
about they're probably more likely to be
subjects right like if we're all you
know you know if I was like oh Rosa you
know
yeah I feel like Rosa did this and Rosa
did did that and runs then and then and
and and then like Leon kiss Rose are you
like no you probably want to be like
Rosa kissing on right you probably want
to put you know it's not straight but if
you're talking about something you're
probably it's probably going to be the
subject of the next sentence so then if
it's you have to put a little accusative
marker on it so this is like how like
the uh marking in the language works and
it's kind of all influenced by this like
interesting semantic uh relationship
um and language models are also aware of
these gradations and it's you know in a
similar like classifying some subjects
an object uh paper that that that that
we wrote we see that language models
also have these gradations right so if
you like again if you like map the
probability of being from that
classifier on the y-axis right we see
that there's a high accuracy right
there's over many languages and all of
them you know on the left we have the
subjects they're classified above on the
right we have the object are classified
below but you know animacy kind of
influences this grammatical distinction
right so like if you're animate and a
subject you're very sure if you're
inanimate and an object you're very sure
anything else you're kind of close to
50. you know and so it's like this this
kind of uh
this kind of um
relation where
the meaning plays into the
um structure is it is reflected in
language models you know and that's not
bad it's good because it's how humans
are or you know it kind of we should
like you know temper our expectations
maybe away from the like fully fully
syntactic things that we're talking
about
um another kind of cool cool example of
like uh
of how meaning can influence you know
what we can say what we can say I've
said from the beginning many times that
all kind of combinations of structures
and words are possible but that's not
strictly true
right so in many cases if something is
like too outlandish we often do just
assume the more plausible interpretation
right it's like there's these
psycholinguistics experiments
um where they kind of test this what's
you know like these kind of these kind
of like giving uh verbs is like you know
the mother gave the daughter the candle
and you could actually like switch that
around you know you could do like so
it's like the date of alternation but
you can switch it around to make them
the mother give the candle to the
daughter
and and then if if you if you switch
around who's actually being given right
so if you actually saying the mother
gave the candle the daughter
um people don't really
um
p p people don't interpret that like in
its literal sense they usually interpret
it as like the mother gave the the
daughter the candle and like of course
Outlanders me meanings you know they're
never impossible to express right
because nothing is
right and so you you can like kind of
spell it out you know it could be like
well the mother they should pick up her
daughter and she handed her to the
candle you know who who is sentient and
then you you could say this but you like
can't you you like can do it simply with
with the give word like like people tend
to interpret it the other way it's like
marking these like less prominent things
and marking them sorry these less
plausible things and marking them more
prominently there's like pervasive
feature that we say like across language
in in all these ways and all these ways
it's like you know also like very like
embedded in the grammar as we saw
earlier in Spanish and Hindi
cool so
another way that uh you know in where
how we see meaning kind of play playing
to to to you know and kind of break
apart this like full compositionality
you know syntax picture right is that
meaning can't always be composed from
Individual words right language is full
of idioms you know sometimes we talk
about idioms you you know you might
think okay there's maybe like 20 of them
you know things like my grandfather
would say you know things about like
chickens and donkeys in Greece they're
all donkeys uh you know we're actually
constantly using constructions that that
you know that we couldn't actually get
from like you know they're kind of like
idiomatic in their little sense right
that we couldn't actually get from like
composing the words right things like I
wouldn't put it past him he's getting to
me these days that won't go down well
with the boss you know there's like so
so so many of these and it's kind of
like a basic part of uh of communication
to kind of use the these little like
canned idiomatic phrases
um you know and like linguist love love
love saying that like oh any string of
words you say is like totally novel you
know and it's like probably true and
I've been speaking for like
50 minutes you know and like probably no
one has said this exact thing like ever
before I just used the compositional
rules of things to make it but actually
most of my real letters is like oh yeah
no totally right like something like
that which is actually people say that
all the time right most of my real
utterances are like people uh say that
all the time you know we have these
little cat things that we love reusing
and that and that you know we reuse them
so much that like they stop making sense
if you break them apart into individual
words right and we even also even have
these constructions that can like take
arguments but like don't really
uh you know so so they're not like
canned words they're kind of like a
canned way of saying something that you
know doesn't really work if you build up
from the syntax right it's like oh he
won't he won't eat shrimp let alone like
oyster right and what does that mean
well it means like I'm defining some
axis of like
you know of like moreness right in this
case probably like selfish and like
shellfish and like weird or something
you know and so it's like well shrimp is
that sweet Source there's more you know
and if I say like okay let alone beef
right the axis like vegetarianism right
so it's like this construction does like
kind of like a a complex thing right
where you're saying like he won't do one
thing let alone the one that's worse
than the dimension you know like it's
like oh she slept after in the way he uh
knitted the night away they drank the
night away right it's like oh this is
like time away thing doesn't actually
you know you like can't really so
otherwise you know like these like this
er er construction like like the the the
bigger they are the more expensive they
are right like the
and I forgot how it goes the bigger they
come the harder they fall right like so
it doesn't even have have to be a yeah
and it was like you know that travesty
of a theory right right like that other
construction there's so many of these
right like so much of how we speak if
you actually try to like do like the
three parts new like semantic Parts up
up from it it won't really make sense
and and so there there's there's been
this work this is more more recent uh
recently kind of come coming to light
and I've been really excited by it
there's texting constructions and large
language models there was just this year
uh paper by Kyle mahalwald uh who was a
postdoc here
um
uh testing the like the a beautiful five
days in Austin Construction right so
it's like the a adjective numeral
um noun construction where it's like
it's like doesn't really work right
because it's like it wouldn't really
work right because so you have uh days
right and there's like many ways
you know and like anything kind of
similar to it right like it's like a
five beautiful days that that doesn't
work right so somehow like this specific
construction is like grammatically
correct to us but like you know you like
you can't say oh five days in Austin
right because like uh five beautiful
days you know you have to like this and
they showed like gp3 is actually like
largely concurrent concurs with humans
on on these things right so on the uh on
the left here the the gray bars we have
a
the the the the things that are
acceptable to humans right so those are
like uh a beautiful five five days in
Austin and five beautiful days in Austin
right those are both acceptable to
humans they do this over like many many
instances of this construction not just
Austin obviously but uh yeah and we say
like GB3 like accepts these you know
those are the gray bars and humans also
accept these though those are the green
triangles and like every other iteration
the human triangles are very low and gp3
is like lower but but but does get
tricked by some things right so it seems
to have this knowledge of this
construction but not as like starkly as
humans do right so the especially like
if you see if you see that that that
third one over there right the five
beautiful days humans don't don't accept
it as much
it's funny to me it sounds almost better
than those rest of them but I guess
these green triangles were uh computed
very uh
uh robustly so
I'm an outlier yeah and GB3 is like
better you know like think thinks those
are better than maybe humans do but
there's this like difference there's
like significant difference between the
gray bars and the orange bars
and then similarly some people tested
the the x or the wire construction right
and so it's like they took examples of
sentences that that were like the x or
the wire construction and then like they
they they took um example centers which
had like an ER followed by an ER but
they weren't or but they weren't
actually the actual the one right it's
like oh the older guys how about the
younger guys right so but so that's not
an extra wire construction and uh and
and you know and then they were like
right if we Mark the ones that are as
positive ones that aren't as negative it
does the latent space of models kind of
like encode this difference right that
that like all this construction kind of
clustered together in a way and they
find that it does
and then the last thing I want to talk
about in this like semantic spacing
after like constructions and all that is
like the meaning of words is like
actually very subtle and sensitive and
it's like influenced by context and all
these like crazy ways right and the
Erica Peterson and Chris Potts from from
the Linguistics Department here did this
like great investigation on a uh you
know uh on the on the ver on the verb
break you know um and it's like that
break can have all these meanings right
like we we think it's like yeah break is
like a word you know like words are
things like table and dog and break that
have like one sense but you know
actually there aren't even senses that
you can enumerate you know like
Riverbank and financial bank and just
like yeah you know break the horse means
tame well like break a 10 bill it means
like spread sweaters like smaller bits
of money right and there's like so many
ways right right like break free and
break even they're just like so so many
ways in which Break
um
you know like its meaning is just so
subtle and influences like kind of Truth
like every word you know or like many
words maybe like table and dog it's like
yeah there's like a set of all things
that are tables or dogs and it's like
kind of describes that set you know
there's maybe some more philosophical
way of going about it but you know so
it's like pocket you know it's like a
pocket but then like you can pocket
something then like it kind of means
Steel in many cases doesn't just mean
put something in your pocket literally
right this is like so
yeah there's like all these ways in
which
um
in in which like the meaning of words is
like sadly almost by everything around
it and and what they do is that don't
don't worry about like what's actually
going on here but you know they've kind
of mapped each sense like a color right
and then when when you start off in
layer one they're all
um I think this is just by like position
embedding right you start off in layer
one and it's just like I think that's
what it is and then you like if you take
all the words past pass them through
like a big model like rubber large right
then then they're kind of all jumbled up
right because they're all just break
right they're just like in different
positions
and then you know by by the end they've
all kind of split up you say oh all the
colors are kind of clustering together
each color is kind of like one of a one
of these meanings right and so and so
they kind of clustered together and
these like kind of is it constructions
again or is it just like you know the
way in which like they kind of isolate
these like really subtle aspects of
meaning
um yeah so then I think a big question
in NLP right is like how do you strike
the balance between like syntax and the
ways that like meaning influences thing
right so well and I pulled out this
quote from a book by John byney uh which
I uh enjoy
um and and I think it kind of bring
brings light like a question that we
should be asking NLP right this book is
about it's like just like a Linguistics
book it's not about LP at all but you
know I think while language is full of
both broad generalizations and items big
properties linguists have been dazzled
by the Quest for General patterns right
that was the first part of this talk you
know
and like of course the actual structures
and categories of language are
fascinating but you know I would submit
or she would submit that what is even
more fascinating is the way that the
general structures arise from and
interact with the more specific items of
language
producing a highly conventional set of
general and specific structures that
allow the expression of both
conventional and novel ideas right it's
kind of like this like Middle Ground
between abstraction and like specificity
uh that like we would want you know that
like humans probably exhibit that would
want our models to to exhibit
yeah
I was wondering you could go back one
slide and just unpack this diagram a
little more because I'm fairly new to
NLP I've never seen a diagram like oh
sorry yeah what what does this mean how
should I you know interpret oh so this
is all like
um you know so if you take you know the
way that that that that like uh words
are you know as you're passing through a
Transformer through through many layers
I just wanted to be like look at how the
colors Cloud cluster but uh yeah and you
pass them through a Transformer many
layers at any one point in that
Transformer you could like say okay how
are the words organized now you know and
you think well I'm going to project that
to two Dimensions from like a thousand
and that's you know maybe a good idea
maybe a bad idea I think there's a lot
of but you know I wouldn't be able to
show them here if there were a thousand
so let's like assume that that's like an
okay thing to be doing
um then then you know so this is what
they've done for like for layer one and
then for layer 24.
and so we could see that that like they
they start off where like the colors are
totally jumbled and they're probably you
know in before layer one you add in the
position embedding so I think I think
that that's what all those clusters are
right so it's like kind of clustering
because you don't have anything to go
off of you know it's like this is break
and it's in position five it's like okay
I guess I'll cluster all the bricks in
position five right but then as you go
as you as you go uh up up the model
right and kind of like all this meaning
is being formed you see these like
senses kind of like come out uh in the
um in in how it organizes things right
so it's like all all these like breaks
kind of like become they're very
specific you know they're very like kind
of subtle versions of breaks now there's
like this working I think it's different
from a lot of NLP work because um it has
like a lot of Labor put into this
labeling right like this is like some
something because because uh you know
the person who this is a linguistic
student right if you like go through
Corpus and label every Break by like
which one of these it means it's like a
lot of work and it's like yeah and so I
think it's the kind of thing that you
wouldn't be able to show otherwise so
it's often not really shown
yeah
cool
so yeah language is characterized by the
fact that it's just amazing the abstract
system right I started off raving about
that and you know and we want our models
to capture that that's why we do all
these compositionality kind of syntax
tests you know but meaning is so rich
and multifaceted right so high
dimensional spaces are much better at
capturing these these subtleties right
we started off talking about word
embeddings in this class right you know
High dimensional space are so much
better this than any rules that we would
come up with being like okay maybe we
could have like break subscript like
break money you know and we're going to
put that into our system and so where do
deep learned learning models where do
they stand now right between surface
level memorization and abstraction you
know and this is what like a lot of
analysis and interpretability work is
trying to understand you know and I
think that what's important to keep in
mind when we're reading and kind of
doing this analysis and interpretability
work is that this is not even a solved
question for humans right like we don't
know exactly where humans stand between
like having an abstract grammar and
having these like these like very like
construction specific and meaning
specific ways that that like things work
by
cool any questions overall on the
importance of semantics and the richness
of human language
yeah
this is a funny question from quite a
bit before but
um he's showing a chart from your
research but
um the model was really really well able
to distinguish anonymous
given its knowledge of subject or object
I was just trying to interpret that crap
and understand what what the sort of
links between them
no no it's not that I think it's here
right yeah yeah so so the main so this
is similar to the other graph where it
was um you know where what it's trying
to to distinguish is a subject from
object but we've just split the test set
into these four ways right it's been
like subject inanimate subject animate
some you know so we just split the test
set right and so like what the uh what
like the two panels and the x-axis are
showing are like these different splits
right and so like okay so things that
are subject and basically the ground
truths the things on the left should be
above 15 things on the right should be
below 50. and that's what's happening
but if we further split it by animate
and inanimate we see that there's this
like influence of of intimacy on the
probability that was a yeah sorry I
rushed over these graphs like kind of I
want to give like a taste of things that
happen but yeah it's good to also
understand fully what's going on
it's cool yeah
yeah
so you were talking about acceptability
so
um I'm assuming for a judging
acceptability means you just asked but
first for like gpt3 like how do you
determine if it defines a sentence
acceptable
I think logic so I think that's what
Kyle Mahal did in this paper right you
could just like take like the
probabilities out put it at the end if
you like mask you know if you like kind
of for gp3 right it's like going left to
right I think there's like other things
that people do sometimes but like yeah
especially for these models they don't
have too much access to apart from like
the like generation and like the like
probability of each generation I think
that you could yeah I think that that
you might want to do that and there's
like you know
you don't want to multiply every larger
together right because then like if
you're multiplying many probabilities
longer longer sentences you know become
like very unlikely right which is like
not true exactly for humans or you know
it's not true in that way for humans so
you know I think there's like things you
should do like ways to control it and
stuff like when you're running an
experiment like this yeah
cool
Okay so
moving on to
um
multilinguality in NLP
so so far we've been talking about
English right all this I haven't been
saying it explicitly all the times but
most things I've said you know apart
from some maybe some differential object
marking examples right they've been kind
of about English about English models
but there's so many languages right
there's like over 7000 languages in the
world where maybe not over there's
around
seven thousand languages in the world
right like it's it's uh it's hard to to
to Define right like what a language is
right it's kind of difficult you know
like even in the case of English right
we have things like it's like Scots
write the language book in Scotland is
that English is like you know something
like Jamaican English you know like
maybe that's a different language right
there's like the different structures
but it's still like clearly like much
more related than anything else right
than like German or something right and
so you know how how do you make a kind
of a multilingual
model uh well so far a big approach to
me you know you take a bunch of
languages this is like all of them and
maybe you're not gonna take all of them
you know maybe I think 100 or something
and you just follow them and just like
one Transformer language model and
there's maybe things you could do like
up sampling sumps they don't have too
much data of you know or like down
sampling something they have too much
data of you know but like this is the
general approach you know what if we
just make one you know like one uh
Transformer language model you know uh
you know like something like a bird it's
usually like a bird type model it's hard
to get a good generation for for like
too many languages you know but but yeah
how about you get one from a language
model for all of these languages
right and so what's cool about this is
that multilingual language models right
they let us they let us share parameters
between High resource languages and low
resource languages right there's a lot
of language in the world really just
most languages in the world which you
could not train like even like a bird
size model for right they're just like
not enough data and there's yeah there's
a lot and there's a lot of work being
done on this and one way to say like
well you know like you know pre-training
and transfer learning they brought us so
much unsuspect uh unexpected success
right and so like you know and and we
get this great linguistic capability and
generality right if we preaching
something in English that we weren't
that we weren't asking for so you know
so will the self-supervised learning
Paradigm you know can it like deliver
between languages so it's like maybe I
can get a lot of the
um a lot of the like linguistic
knowledge like the more General stuff
from like just all the higher resource
languages and then kind of apply it to
the low resource languages right like a
bilingual person doesn't have like two
totally separate parts of their self
right that like have learned language
there's probably some sharing some way
that like things are like in the same
space like and Linguistics are broadly
the same right and so and so and so you
know we we have this like attempt to
like bring NLP to like some still very
small subset of the 7000 language in the
world we can look at it through two
lenses right on on the one hand you know
languages are remarkably diverse so
we'll go over some some of the cool ways
the language in the world vary you know
and so there's multilingual NLP capture
the specific differences of of different
languages on the other hand you know
languages are similar to each other in
many ways and so does multilingual NLP
capture the parallel structure between
languages
so you know just just to go over some
ways like you know really understanding
like how like diverse languages can be
you know in around this is a a quote
from a book but um you know in around a
quarter of the world's languages every
statement right like every time you use
a verb must specify the type of Source
on which it is based right this is kind
of like a part you know how we have like
tense in English where we like you know
kind of everything you say is like kind
of either in the past or the present or
the future tense right and so like an
example in uh in tariana these are again
from from the book right it's not a
language I I know any right but it's you
know you you have this like marker and
bold at the end right and so and so when
you say something like uh Jose has
played football right you if you put
like the car marker that means that we
saw it right it's kind of like the
visual evidential marker right and
there's uh and there's kind of a
non-visual market that kind of means we
heard it right so so if you say you know
so if you say statement you you could
say we heard it right there's a like we
infer it from Visual Evidence right so
if it's like oh his like cleats are gone
and he is also gone but like and people
you know and we see people going to play
football right or see people coming back
I guess from playing football because in
the past right that means like you know
so so we can infer it and so you can put
this right and there's like um
uh you know or like if he plays football
every Saturday you know and it's
Saturday we you you would use a a
different marker right or like um if
someone has told you if it's here say
you would use a different marker right
so this is like a this is like a
um a part of the grammar right that like
to to me at least right like I don't
speak any language that has this it
seems like it's it it it seems like very
cool and like different from like
anything I would ever think would be
like a part of the grammar right but it
is
um
or like especially like a compulsory
part of the grammar right but but it is
right and you can like map out I wanted
to include some maps from walls the
world atlasive linguistic structure
that's always like so fun
um you know you could like map out all
the language right like I only speak uh
white dot languages which are like no
grammatical evidentials you know if you
want to say whether you heard something
or saw it you have to say it like in
words right but uh but there's many
languages you know as
um very yeah especially in uh in in in
the the Americas right Diana's I think
uh Brazilian language from like
up by the border with uh oh yeah but uh
yeah
the you know while we're looking at like
language typology Maps right and so like
this this like language organization
like in categorization Maps uh the the
most like the classic one right is again
like the the the subject object in verb
order right so as you said English has
SVO order but there's just so so many
orders that uh you know kind of like
almost all the possible ones are are
attested you know some languages have no
dominant order like Greek Greek so like
a language that I speak natively has a
dominant order you would say you would
move things around for emphasis or
whatever
um
um yeah and you see like and here you
know we're seeing some some like diverse
using typology we're also seeing some
Tendencies right like some are just so
much more common than others right and
this is like again something which like
people talk about so much right it's
it's like a very uh big part yeah it's
like a huge part of linguistic why are
some more common where some others like
a basic fact of language is something
which happened you know it's just like
just the fact like how discourse Works
maybe you know like that's that's more
preferred for many people to say
something you know and there's a lot of
opinions on this
uh another way though that language is
there you know it's like the number of
morphemes they have per word right like
some languages are like you know like
Vietnamese classically just like very
isolating like kind of like each um you
know like each kind of thing you want to
express like tense or something is going
to be in in a different word you know in
English we actually combine kind of
tenses we have things like bubble right
like you know like like throwable or
something right and then like in in some
languages they're just like really so
much stuff is expressed in morphemes
right and so you can have languages
especially in like Alaska and Canada uh
a lot of languages there in like
Greenland where you have like
um and these are all like one one
language family
um you you can have like kind of whole
sentences expressed with just like
things things that get tacked on to uh
to to the verb right so you have to have
things things like uh
the you know like the object and the um
or I guess in this case you start with
the object again you have kind of like
the verb and the like whether it's
happening or not happening and who said
it like what they're said in the future
and all that just kind of all put in you
know these like quote unquote like
sentence words right it's like a very
different way of a language we're
working than English works like at all
right
um I just want to know like what these
dots mean because like in the U.S the
top right is gray like in the Northeast
but in the Pacific Northwest it's yellow
it's like is that different dialects for
like the same American English oh no the
visual indigenous languages oh I see
yeah yeah so so English is uh just uh
this one dot uh in here spread uh in
amongst all the like Cornish and Irish
and stuff oh yeah so English was like in
Great Britain yeah
yeah and that's why yeah that's why like
all this like really and that's why I
like all this like evidential stuff is
happening in uh in like the Americas
right because there's like a lot of very
often the indigenous languages the
Americas are like the classic like very
evidentially marking uh ones which are
the pink ones yeah you said that
normally we use like a bird style model
for multilingual models because it's
difficult for natural language
generation across languages yeah uh I
mean I guess intuitively that makes
sense right because of the subtleties
and the Nuance between the languages
when you're producing it but is there
like a reason that
um like a particular reason that's been
so much harder to make developments on
a good generation is just like harder
right like to get something like you
know like gpt3 or something it means
like really like a lot of data and maybe
like it's kind of like I think there are
can I think of any are there any
G sharp newshards encodone yeah I can't
really think of any like you know like
encoder decoder as you said you know
like a kind of big multilingual models
you know of course like gpd3 has this
thing where if you're like how do you
say this in French you'll be like you
say it like this you know so it's like
if you've seen all of the data it's
going to include a lot of languages but
this kind of like multilingual model
where you'd be like right you know be as
good as gpt3 but in this other language
you know I think it just it's just you
need a lot more data to get that kind of
coherence right as opposed to like
yeah as opposed to something if you do
like text infilling or something which
is like how the bridge style models are
then you get like very good even if the
text and feeling you know um
uh performance isn't great for every
language you can actually get very very
good embeddings to work with for a lot
of those languages
cool now for just like a one last
language diversity thing I think this is
interesting interesting the motion event
because it's like this is actually you
know it's not it's like languages that
you know many of us know I'm gonna talk
about Spanish but uh it's actually
something which you might not have
thought about but then once you see
you're like oh actually that's like
actually it's like how like everything
works
um so in English right the manner of
motion is usually expressed on the verb
right so you can say something like the
bottle floated into the cave right and
so like the fact that it's floating is
on the verb and the fact that it's going
in is kind of on this satellite
um well like in Spanish the direction of
motion is usually expressed on the verb
uh Greek Greek is like this too I feel
like most Indo-European languages are
not like this or actually like English
so like most like language like Europe
to like North India tend to to not be
like this right and so you would say
like
right so you'd have like so used to so
the floating has is not usually put on
the main verb and like in English you
could actually say like red like the
bottle entered the cave floating it's
just like maybe not what you would say
right and and similar like in Spanish
you can't say the other way around these
are called like satellite framing
language and verb framing languages like
really affects how you would kind of
like say most you know like kind of how
everything works right it's kind of like
a division that's like you know pretty
attested of course it's not a full
division right it's not like this
exclusive categorization China uh
Chinese I think off often has you
structured where there's like two verb
slots right where where you could have
both a manner of motion and a direction
of motion kind of in the in the like the
one verb verbs thought none of them have
to go kind of like after playing some
some some different role right so these
are like you know there's all these ways
in which like languages are just
different you know from like things that
that maybe we didn't even think could
like be in a language like things are
like we do right but we don't realize
that in some some sometimes you're just
like so so different in these like
subtle ways
and so uh you know and so going to the
other end your language is so different
they're also very alike right so like
you know there's there's like you know
this idea like is there like a universal
grammar some like abstract structure
that all that unite all languages right
this is like a huge question Linguistics
and you know the question is can we
Define an abstraction where we can all
say like all language or some part
version of it there's like other ways of
thinking about universals like all
languages like tend to be one way or
tend to be like languages that tend to
be one way also tend to be some other
way and there's like a third way of
thinking about
um a universals that's like languages
all deal in similar types of relations
you know like subjects objects you know
like types of modifiers right like the
universal dependencies project was like
uh
um
uh a way of kind of saying like maybe we
can make dependencies kind of for all
language the way that doesn't shoehorn
them into each other you know and uh
yeah I guess like what was it called rrg
like relational something grammar you
know was also kind of this idea that
maybe one way to think about all
languages together is like the kind of
relations they Define you know
and um and you know ask me ask me about
kind of like the chomp skin and the
Greenberg and stuff you want and how it
relates to NLP I think like there
there's a lot to to say there it's kind
of yeah it's it's slightly more
difficult so maybe it's easier to think
of the of this third one in terms of NLP
right and like back to the subject
object relation stuff if we look at it
across languages right we see that
they're kind of encoded in parallel
because classifiers right those
classifiers that we're training they're
like as accurate in their own language
as they are in other languages right
their own language being um red and
other languages being black right it's
not like wow if I take a multilingual
model and I train these classified
induction one classify in one language
it's like going to be so good at itself
and like so bad at everything else right
they're kind of interspersed they're
clearly like on the top end the red dots
yeah
and uh and UD relations right so
Universal dependencies like the kind of
like dependency relations they're also
encoded in parallel ways this is this
work that uh John John has done right
again main thing to take from from this
example is that like the colors
clustered together right it's like if
you if you train kind of like a parser
on or like you know parse uh
classification on one language and kind
of transfer it to another you see these
clusters form for the other language
right so it's like these ideas of how
like things relate together right like a
like kind of noun modifier you know all
that kind of stuff they they they do um
clustered together in these parallel
ways across across languages you know
and so language specificity is also
important
um
I might skip over this but you know it
seems with like so maybe sometimes some
languages are shoehorned into others in
various ways uh and maybe part of this
is that data quality it's very variable
in multilingual corpora right it's like
so so if you take like all these
multilingual corporate there's like an
audit of them and like for like all
these various like multilingual
corporate like 20 of languages they're
less than 50 correct meaning like 50 of
it was often like just links or like
just something random I was like yeah
that might be like some language but but
it was not at all
and and like maybe the way maybe we
don't want too much parameter sharing
right like uh Africa is a reason uh it's
a kind of recent Bird model trained like
only on African language you know maybe
like having too much too high risks too
high resources like harming you know and
there's work here at Stanford being done
in the same direction you know another
uh
uh yeah another a recent cross-lingual
model xlmv came out which is like why
should we be doing vocabularies sharing
you know like you just have like a big
vocabulary each language gets like its
own words it's probably going to be
better and it is it kind of like knocks
out similar models or smaller
vocabularies which are like maybe you
know computers the same in English and
French it should be shared you know
maybe it's better to separate out things
you know it's like hard to like kind of
find this balance between let's keep
over this paper too it's very cool and
there's a link there so look at it but
yeah we we want language generality but
we also want to preserve diversity and
so how is multilingual NLP doing you
know especially with effects like
dialects you know there's so many
complex issues for multilingual NLP to
be dealing with
how how can deep learning work for low
resource languages you know what are the
ethics of working NLP for low resource
languages who like wants their language
in in big models who like wants a
language to be translated you know these
are all like very important ethical
issues in multilingual NLP and so after
looking at structure Beyond structure
multilinguality in models
um
I hope you've been yeah but I hope you
know that Linguistics is a way of you
know investigating what's going on in
Black Box models uh the subtleties
linguistic analysis they can help us
understand what we want or expect from
the models that we work with and like
even though we're not reverse
engineering human language uh linguistic
insights I hope I've convinced you they
still have a place in understanding you
know the models that we're working with
the models that we're dealing with and
you know and in so many more ways beyond
what what we've discussed here you know
like uh language acquisition language
and vision and like instructions and
music uh discourse conversation and
communication and like so so many other
ways
cool thank you if there's any more
questions you can come ask me time's up
[Applause]